i used ar to avoid a catastrophic
disaster let me explain in this video
we're exploring arkey an architectural
app that uses ar technology to portray
an unbuilt 3d model in the built
environment aki claims it is a must-have
app for all architects and designers
today we're going to put that to the
test we're going to be covering the
basics of the archi app the best and the
worst case scenarios how much archi
actually costs in the real world and
also my verdict on this app let's get
started with the basics of aki once you
download and install the app on your
ipad you can then go ahead and load it
up all you have to do is press that
magic blue button in the middle to
import one of your fbx 3d model files
now this can be exported from any 3d
modeling software and directly imported
into archi through the use of a cloud
based link so go ahead onto dropbox
onedrive whatever you use drop that file
in and paste that link in there after
that you're gonna see aki load this 3d
model on the screen which you can then
manipulate and play with the on-screen
options allow you to do a few things
basically on the screen you can change
the time of the day and understand the
sun paths across this building you can
change the materials of the building you
can go ahead and create an exploded
animation to actually explode this whole
building into pieces which is a really
cool useful little effect that can be
used for social media or anything in the
works and you can also add notes to your
project directly onto the 3d model so
it's great as a collaborative tool
between clients between projects just so
you can really understand this model in
3d but where aki really stands out is
its ar functionality and its augmented
reality ability to do 3d objects in the
real world so what can you do in ar in
the real world well first of all you can
take any house or any model that you
have and show it in the real world in
the real environment exactly where it
needs to go aki allows you to place a
physical real-world pin or an anchor as
they call it in the actual project so
that model doesn't move now doesn't move
is a subjective term but nonetheless the
technology is there to basically place
your model exactly where it needs to go
from there you can also use the
transform tool to move it left and right
slightly to be able to actually move
giant shapes in the real world because
it's not always easy to move a huge ar
object the size of a house by simply
dragging on bits and pieces of that 3d
model everything that you can do on the
screen options like the materials the
time of day and everything i spoke about
you can still do in ar but it's more so
about really understanding the project
in 3d once it's in ar you can also flick
through a series of different color
schemes models layers or whatever you
want by simply importing another fbx
model that overlays instantly over the
top of that one when you manage to scale
up your project to the real world size
place it perfectly with any of the great
functionality tools that they have you
then have the ability to actually walk
through an unbuilt project
now this is exactly how you can avoid a
catastrophic disaster simply by walking
through a project understanding exactly
the lay of the land and what it might
look like in the context you can change
something on paper before it's ever
built now i say this all the time and it
is significantly cheaper to change a
line on paper than it is to move a wall
in real life this ar function is
incredibly invaluable in the grand
scheme of a project when you are
spending hundreds of thousands if not
millions of dollars on something that is
yet to be constructed let's talk about
the best case scenario for me personally
it was a flat side and if it's a flat
site it is easy all you have to do is
load the ar model expand it to its full
natural size and then place a pivot
point on that actual 3d model to be able
to drag it pin it exactly where it needs
to go then you have the freedom and
flexibility to walk around this full 3d
model that isn't there in real life it
is a little bit trippy to walk through
holding an ipad looking past the ipad
and going oh that's actually not there
you have to be careful of the real world
scenario rather than just the ar version
that's on the tablet itself now full
disclosure it did still take me about
five minutes to place this 3d model on a
flat site once i understood all of the
technologies in our key move the pins
dragged it around placed it to a real
world object so it didn't move around
too much i finally was able to
understand the value of this app it does
take a little bit of getting used to it
does take a little bit of playing and
understanding how to use the app before
you go ahead and then just dive straight
in but on a flat side it is relatively
easy once it's fully modeled you can
really understand the project you can
figure out if there's any faults any
flaws where the landscaping is where the
window placement is how that affects the
physical already built world is there a
giant power pole in front of your
building that you simply forgot about or
was that power pole perfectly planned
and placed you can use this ar model to
genuinely and fully understand what's
going to happen on site before that ever
happens now nothing is sunshine and
rainbows unfortunately we do have a
worst case scenario and the worst case
actually isn't too bad it's just a
little bit more frustrating than
anything so i have this site it's a
tiered site on the side of a hill the
project itself entails a bit of cutting
and feeling of the site which means
we're actually building underground of
the real world environment as i
mentioned before aki uses the real world
environment to understand how to place a
model into it so when i try to place a
3d model onto a tiered site that's
actually meant to cut into the project
it does struggle even though i placed an
anchor and positioned it into the real
world the model itself isn't able to
sink through the earth or push back into
the earth the rear of the model is
always using one part of the mesh in the
real world and doesn't allow me to push
that model into the environment so
unfortunately this was extremely
frustrating because it took me a very
very long time to get anything that
resembles a real world project on a
sloping site so that for me just means i
have to plan and prep a little bit
longer before i show anybody this ar
model because it takes more time now i'm
not saying it is impossible in any way
shape or form if i had planned a little
bit more and taken out the 3d elements
in that model that were going
underground and weren't going to be seen
this would have been a very very simple
process the site itself also had
extremely overgrown grass strong winds
it was raining part of the day and it
just wasn't the ideal ar conditions so
overall anything can seem to be done on
this app sometimes it just is a little
bit frustrating so far this all sounds
fantastic and amazing but how much does
archi actually cost well first of all rk
is 100 free for the basic features the
basic 3d features let you import a 3d
model utilize the ar functionality to
view models in both 3d and ar scale them
up to size and it also allows you to do
some offline storage of your actual
project however if you want the more
in-depth version of arky to fully let
you utilize everything like i've
mentioned today you do need the paid
version or the pro features
unfortunately the pro features don't
come cheap thankfully for me this video
today is sponsored by archie so they
were kind enough to donate one year free
of aki to me so i could fully understand
this and be able to provide my true
honest opinion back to you guys if you
go out right now and purchase archi in
australia for a one year membership it
would cost you 333.99
or it would cost you
28.99 per month
so by no way is arkey a cheap app it is
not something you're going to go out and
spend five dollars on and be happy it is
a very expensive app for a very good
reason it does something very specific
very very well so what's my verdict
should you a download it b pay for it or
c completely skip the app
well personally i think you should 100
download it for free start utilizing the
archi app and understand exactly how it
works with your workflow where you can
utilize it how far you can push the
abilities of the 3d free app and then if
you're finding yourself as a
professional using it more and more in
your everyday work life with clients
then i genuinely do believe it is worth
the 333
for a one year subscription to be able
to showcase these ar models in full 3d
and in their full glory that's all from
me if you enjoyed the video you'll find
similar content to the right on this
playlist if you love the video i'd
appreciate it if you smash the subscribe
button down below and as always my name
is david thomich i'll see you next
monday